president biden snapping on the world
stage and it wasn't at vladimir putin
biden now being accused of getting a
free pass after blowing up on a reporter
asking about the summit
what do you do
and the white house is facing scrutiny
for protecting the president by limiting
who he
is allowed to ask him a question but
biden facing some criticism for lashing
out but was
quickly forgiven we've not seen him do
is answer questions like that without
his aides
screaming at him to stop i have never
seen a president covering the last four
of them
who is so protected by his aides in
terms of
often not wanting him to answer some
questions there he is apologizing for
the way he responded to my question that
is completely unnecessary from the
president he did not have to apologize
and despite the outburst many in the
media are praising biden for his
performance with the russian president
i can't think of a more successful
diplomatic
trip in the 21st century than this one
the handshake
biden looked putin in the eye with a
smile putin looked away
at one point i wrote professor biden
because i thought he was trying to
basically be above it
be above the meeting my insight watching
the press conference yesterday was
there was a kind of poetry in his prose
and that is
the test and perhaps the legacy defining
moment for president biden
whether his personal relationships will
change anything
as our 46th president makes the case
that diplomacy
dialogue and democracy are america's
greatest exports greg
[Laughter]
that was amazing that montage at first i
didn't have anything to talk about but
now now i am that is amazing
amazing when a democrat is in charge we
know that there's bias but
the hacks like morning joe their true
colors come out it's amazing
they talk about poetry in his prose
historic moment one for the ages
how do how do even the older venerable
journalists
how do they get to an age like what joe
scarborough is what he's like
70 i don't know how do they get to be
that age without accruing
any self-awareness like they can't even
hear themselves if you look at these
journalistic leftovers like meacham and
rather and carl bernstein and brian
williams
it's an evidence of a life in a bubble
a bubble where they can't see that
they've become a parody of their own
bias it's it's it's that was bonkers
that was absolutely bonkers i understand
though that they're pleased by the
president it's like my parents
when i used to play basketball for saint
gregs it's like i i i would only get one
no i don't even know what it was i only
played for like one minute
in the each game and my parents were so
grateful
like that i didn't pee myself right and
that and there was one time i actually
sunk
a free throw and my dad fell off a chair
that's the way the media is with biden
he's like
me playing fifth grade basketball at st
gregory's in san mateo california
one of the things i thought was the most
interesting though was somebody
that was a a criticism from somebody
like jeff zeleny
of cnn who's he as he said he's covered
several presidents
he said he has never seen uh a president
so protected by his aides or even
screamed at to stop
taking questions or stop talking i can't
imagine ever screaming at a president
first i'd just like to ask the gutfeld
family to please send photos of greg
playing basketball in fifth grade
hope you're watching well first first
with the
the questions right they do that for
three reasons dana they do that because
biden
can't remember the names in the faces of
the reporters and you can't see them
if you see him he's squinting and
looking around so
you have the list of reporters because
when they look up they might not
remember somebody's name uh i think
trump knew the reporters names and faces
pretty well
engraved on the back of his well i think
he knew their names and faces very well
also
they need to create a finite number of
people to call on because you have to
shorten this thing because the longer
joe talks the worse it gets
and creating a list is like creating a
vip list
you want to be on the list it's human
nature so
the reporters during the week they
jockey and see if they can
shade their coverage to be so flattering
that they get to be on the list and then
the
biden communication shop can say you
were a good girl this week you were a
good boy this week you get to be on the
list
so the people that know biden best know
he can't hack it with the press and the
media knows that too even though the
media is there to help joe
they want the democratic party to do
well so it's an arrangement
a pathetic arrangement between the media
and the white house to protect
joe from himself and that doesn't serve
the american people well
now to shower praise on this summit is
ridiculous there was no doctrine there's
no memorable line
there were gaff's galore he handed our
enemy a list of targets that we don't
want to be hit
and then to hear someone like meacham
say there was poetry in
prose meacham is his speechwriter msnbc
doesn't reveal that but meacham is the
speechwriter for joe biden
so that's just an inside job they're
doing and then chuck todd who i feel
sorry for i don't want to knock him too
hard
but he doesn't believe that stuff what
he said he's angling for a sit down with
the president
but the thing is digging the the news
that got made out of the press
conference were actually not from the
uh the list that he was going to call on
it was from the shouted questions from
peter ducey and caitlin collins
right and caitlin collins delivered the
softest
of softballs that trump ever got right
right
because trump was getting hammered by
the
the bloviating losers all day long every
day
the posturing so i want to see at least
one kind of trump day a month maybe
every six months at the white house
where they just
fire questions at him and they just
hammer joe biden
and there is not enough string cheese
and teddy grams
to prevent joe biden from having a
volcanic eruption he would not be able
to handle it
just a couple of a couple things it's
the job of the press corps
to report on whether joe biden is in
decline
or not these chattering ciphers will
never ever investigate that it's kind of
important given he's the leader of the
free world
but i will give him this he still knows
how to manipulate
these members of the press that line
you're the brightest people in the
country
he's been on the he's been on the grift
he's been
in this racket for so long he knows that
it only takes
one compliment to have these like thin
skinned insecure
reporters back right in his little coin
purse
harold if you're at the white house
though and understanding that there is
some bias and maybe like they they would
probably look at this summit and say
you know net plus uh maybe not the best
what did what did joe scarborough say
the best diplomatic 21st century
i'm not sure i would go that far but the
white house probably feels pretty good
about the trip
yeah and according to the polling data
the country feels pretty good about the
about his trip look every president
tries to control the narrative that
comes out of
his his and one day we'll say her press
conference and her and his meetings i
hope not
biden like reagan and even like your
former boss and like
bill clinton all tried to ensure that
the one or two messages
they wanted out for the day got out so
they would try to limit and maybe
you know i i take jeff zelen in his word
he's never seen anything like this um
but every president's done it two look
again i differ i think the proof will be
into putting 30 to 60 days from today if
we if you all invite me back in 60 days
and we see that there's been nothing
nothing that's happened after this
meeting with with putin that we've had
more attacks that we have not responded
then i think one would have to say that
everything is being said
that that's being talked about around
this table is largely right
but the data the polling data says that
people thought he did a good job
uh and he got a little testy with of all
reporters a reporter from cnn so
it wasn't fox it was it was young mr
ducey who asked i thought one of the
most pointed questions
until your point dana he asked that not
as a chosen person he he yelled it out
at the president president that's right
and that's why reporters yell questions
i didn't know they pulled this by the
way that was fast they pulled everything
that was very fast
there's a poll on the pole yeah which
was high to it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else